that's intoxicating me that is that is
the very thing that my success is
predicated on
is i'm i'm i'm relentless
like let the full weight of that word
wash over you i am relentless
i will not stop i'm like the [ __ ]
terminator
i believe that each and every one of us
has the power within ourselves
to create the life that we really want
and i want to help give you the tools to
make that happen
i'm danica patrick and i'm pretty
intense
today on the show i'm talking to tom
bilyeu
who started out with a job that he was
not super inspired by
and decided to leave and the partner
said you can't go
you have to stay what can we do with you
and he's like i want to start a
nutritional company so
he was one of the founders of quest
nutrition which of course made quest bar
which within five years turned into a
billion dollar company
he has since then resigned from there as
well because he's inspired yet again
to be an inspirational guru he is a
total entrepreneur he has a
show called impact theory uh which i
went on which was a lot of fun
and uh truth be told we're actually
shooting a lot of episodes from his
house so he's also very very kind
um but he is just a you know really deep
guy
a really introspective guy and we
covered all a lot of bases that have to
do with the mind and how you operate in
the world and intention
and being inspired so i hope you really
enjoy it
so we have something in common uh
i love the matrix i
love the matrix so tell me why you love
the matrix
the matrix is the perfect metaphor for
the human experience
it is a movie entirely about belief
so the whole thing that morpheus is
trying to get neo to understand
is that he doesn't have to have anything
special he simply has to allow himself
to believe
that he exists in a system that system
has rules some of the rules have to be
followed but some of them can be broken
but before you do any of that you have
to understand them and so
neo goes on this journey not to um do
anything other than realize if he
believes he can make the jump he can
make the jump
and that to me is life i mean we were
talking about this before
right so would that be him controlling
100
of himself or 50 because you said your
belief on that
yeah so here's the thing i want us to be
completely blank slates
i don't want there to be any genetic
component
component to our experience of life
whatsoever
the bad news is everything that science
shows us is that that isn't true and i
would say that in your own life you can
probably think of people who
fall below what i call minimum
requirements and whether that's somebody
who truly has
um some sort of intellectual deficiency
and they're a special needs person or
you just you're around them and they
don't have the emotional intelligence or
whatever and they're like full-blown
spectrum
and they're they're really going to
struggle in life and so we can
understand how somebody
in that sort of tragic situation through
no fault of their own is always going to
be a little bit behind the eight ball
um i'm just saying that so life seems to
be a spectrum
and the sciences coming out right now
will say that
some percentage is determined by your
genetics height for instance is an easy
one for people to get behind i could
tell you to think all day
sure you're not going to get anything
that's true so it's like now it just
becomes a question of what percentage of
that
what percentage is that that's sort of
locked in stone i'll ballpark it at 50
now part of the reason i'm in a ballpark
at 50 is i get so excited about the
other 50
because like you i believe that whatever
amount it is that's changeable
it will alter your life in ways that are
so profound you would be unrecognizable
on the other side
so whether it's 90 that you can change
10 you can change i don't care what the
number is
i believe to the core of my being that
the
average person can transform their life
so profoundly as to effectively make the
following statement true
anything is possible so i live in a
world saying you don't need 100
then definitively not to make great
changes you can you can do it with 10
20 30 40. and the easy example to give
since we've already got people to buy in
that height is not the
uh the thing that is changeable you've
got a guy
like um spud webb you've got a guy like
mugsy bogues um who mugsy bogues is the
shortest person ever to play in the nba
and he was five foot three
and he was extraordinary and when you
see him play against the michael jordan
you realize that what he learned to do
was take advantage of how short he was
so he could steal the ball away from
them as they're dribbling it down
because he's so close to the ball
so for the most part people have to do
like big dives to try and steal it if
they're dribbling they usually wait till
they try and pass it
but it's very easy for him because he
was just right there so he
from a stats perspective is one of the
greatest point guards to ever play the
game of basketball and he was five foot
three
so that to me is just like he wanted it
badly enough and he grew up in the inner
cities and that gets into a whole thing
when he was asked like how did you get
so good he was like i was so desperate
to get out of the inner cities
i just poured all my time and attention
into this
so how did your world or what was your
paradigm shift then
before watching the matrix and after
i really want the matrix to have been
like this
demarcation line in my life it sadly was
not
but when i saw the movie it was to this
day the single most extraordinary
film-going experience of my life i'm
gonna be a little indulgent and tell a
story yeah so
that's what you're here for i'm obsessed
with comic books
and i just graduated film school i felt
like a total failure
and my friend partly trying to cheer me
up was like hey
come to this comic book convention with
me and it was held in the place where
they hold the academy awards
believe it or not at the time and so i
was like oh my god
i have to do this the academy awards
location and comic books perfect i go
there and i'm like looking around this
is back when comic book conventions were
dicey at best it felt like a garage sale
and i go around a corner of this like
garage sale and all of a sudden it's
like a huge room and up on the stage
is um keanu reeves carry anne moss
joe pantaleon wow i don't remember if
lawrence fishburne was there but
definitely joel silver and his son
and they were giving tickets away to the
matrix premiere that night on the
backlot of warner brothers studios and
so i was like
oh my god like this is so incredible so
i take my ticket i go to see the movie
and i was as a film student i was a
psycho about movie theaters i had to be
quiet and want people talking i sat in
exactly the center i used to measure it
i'd go 30 minutes early the whole night
and so if people talk to me noise i'd
have a [ __ ] stroke
and i go in this theater and the moment
where
the um the agent is talking to the cops
right at the very beginning
and he said you know um i think we can
handle one little girl
and he goes no officer your men are
already dead
and then they cut to trinity and she
jumps into the air and freezes
myself and everyone in the audience went
ah
like everyone screamed all at once i had
never experienced anything
where i was like i'm making noise in a
movie theater this is crazy
but i was so moved by how they were
filming this thing i knew i was going to
be in from the jump
and then the movie just is this
philosophical treatise by
artists at the absolute height of their
powers
and it is it literally is the perfect
metaphor for the human existence
i found it to be a fascinating movie
from a lot of perspectives and
i feel like it's one of those movies
where you see on in you know social
media they're like
the matrix was a documentary yes i have
a shirt that says
that well there's there's there's
scientists that have said that they can
break
every element down out there into zeros
and ones
yeah that's that's crazy a little blow
your mind information theory is
is pretty freaky and the odds that
weren't the odds just speaking
statistically the odds that were in a
simulation are it's almost certain
um so you're on the elon musk i'm not i
actually don't that's what he said
he's talking purely from an odds
perspective so i don't know that he
either is saying that we actually are in
a simulation i don't know i don't think
he'll
saying the odds are yeah so
statistically speaking like it actually
does make sense but someone also has to
be the base reality it's entirely
possible that's
us um to me because it doesn't matter i
don't spend a lot of time thinking about
it
that's true i mean i think that if we do
and my dad would tell me this too you're
worrying about stuff that you can't
figure out it's like
it's an interesting topic though and i
think it opens your mind up to other
things and
and and really expands you and stretches
you
and you know i read a book called the
holographic universe and that'll expand
you and
and really make open your mind up to
possibilities so
while it's you know whether it's true or
not true
it doesn't change our reality what are
you gonna do
quit yeah exactly you know um
i read that you you know you're one of
those guys that
that takes the red pill is this accurate
mm-hmm okay
now the bad news is an internet parlance
taking the red pill now has been
co-opted and means something else
the only thing i mean by taking the red
pill yeah go ahead and explain yourself
so i'm 100 a true seeker along with you
and so
um what are some examples of times that
you've taken the red pill
instead of the blue pill and what is
that done like what paths has that led
you down
so the only way that i was able to get
good at this gary
the truth will be psychologically
damaging i can pretty much guarantee you
that it's definitely going to probably
and it's probably going to create change
so for sure so
uh and to that point like those are the
moments that were the biggest
changes for me so to get good at
business one of the realizations that i
had to have that was that was really
quite hard to swallow
was i had been telling everybody for
decades that i was going to be rich
and this is when i was dirt poor and i
finally meet these entrepreneurs
and they're basically um
showing me that the way that i'm living
doesn't make any sense and they're much
smarter than me
and i i just i'm really really
struggling to keep up and it's making me
feel badly about myself and so
one day i started arguing for this idea
because it was mine i didn't have the
clarity of that at the time but i'm
arguing for an idea that i know is wrong
and there's a voice inside my head
screaming
you know if you can convince them to do
this it's worse for the business
and maybe because they just got tired of
arguing they finally gave in and said
fine we'll do it your way and so i had
this emotional crisis and i realized
do i actually want to be rich or do i
just want to feel good about myself
because i fought for that idea because i
wanted to win
and if i just want to be right and i
just want to feel good about myself
then no judgment and and that that's the
one
moment i'm i'm like kind of proud of
because um
i i didn't judge myself i just said look
if what you really want to do is feel
good about yourself go back to being the
king of remedial jobs which is how i
used to refer to myself
and just feel good like go where you're
going to be the smartest person in the
room
and on the other hand if what you really
want is to actually be rich then you
have to give up on feeling good about
yourself because these guys are the
surest path to your success
and i thought okay neither of those are
winning solutions i need to feel good
about myself right it was pretty clear
to me that
when somebody believes that they will
never feel good about themselves again
they commit suicide
it'd actually be pretty reasonable if if
it were true the problem is
it's a false belief you can and will
feel good about yourself again
um but just in those moments they feel
so all-encompassing
and so i thought okay i need to feel
good about myself but and this
unfortunately unlike the matrix which
planted a seed that developed slowly
over
you know 10 or 15 years and finally
becomes the dominant metaphor of my life
to sort of close a circle
on what i was saying earlier like that's
how that one played out this
was a line in the sand a a moment of
inspiration a moment of clarity that
my life can literally be before this red
pill moment and after
and what i realized was oh i could build
my self-esteem around something else
because in building my self-esteem
around being smart
being right being good being effective
all of those things were
leading me down a dead end of arguing
for bad ideas because
then i can be right and i can feel good
about myself but it would actually take
me away from my goal
so i could become truly goal oriented if
i became a slave to the truth
if i always wanted to know am i actually
moving towards my goal or not
and the reason i said that that the
truth can be psychologically painful
is because you're going to have to
accept that it's all your fault now when
people hear that
they they shut down emotionally they
can't handle it they think i'm victim
blame it or whatever
and all i'm saying is i'm not even
interested in blame like that
that that isn't why i use that the word
fault to me isn't about self-punishment
it's not about feeling bad
it's about recognizing that you're in
control that you can make a different
decision and get a different outcome
so that's all i mean when i say it's all
your fault you're
you're going to be victimized in life
and you probably can't by yourself or by
others by others by yourself too for
sure
but that at least you can control but
you're going to be victimized by others
but you get to decide whether you
identify as a victim and once you
whatever you identify as you will act in
accordance with so you have to be
so [ __ ] careful like what you repeat
to yourself just nice and simple what
you repeat to yourself that you are
is what you are yeah for sure
so what are some instances
that you you know
you took a leap or you took a chance or
you made a big
change so first of all i think it's
important for the audience to understand
i'm not afraid of change
right um i probably seek change um
so when i left that's unique to seek
change that is
that is very weird you have a pattern or
a rhythm to your change like is it
every two years every five years every
year every month like do you feel like
it's gonna make a certain really
interesting never thought about kind of
because i i have a pattern like
interesting yeah like every couple of
years
i have an expression where every couple
of years my life changes in ways that i
would never expect
which is scary as hell but it's also
really exciting as long as you're
open and moving forward it's exciting
but it does mean things are gonna you're
gonna have to let go of things
yeah i that is as you were describing it
that's so intoxicating and exciting to
me like every word out of your mouth
except the words scary
um i was like yeah yeah yeah um to give
you an idea
in in la i've lived in la for 25 years
i've never been in one place for more
than six years
and that was like unheard of for me
normally it was two to three years and
then i'm
gonna move um every ten years i
intentionally completely reinvent my
skill set
i'm haunted by a quote which is genius
as a young man's game
and when i heard that quote it was tied
to the statistics around nobel prizes
nobel prizes are given to people in
their 60s for work they did in their 20s
and i thought uh i can't i can't be a
part of that so wow
and this is one of the things you and i
talked about on my podcast was like i'm
i'm really obsessed with what are the
values that people construct for
themselves that they say
this is important which is all
subjective it doesn't it's not going to
be universal for everybody but
like they've decided this is important
sure and one thing i've decided is
important for me is that my future
is always bigger than my past so
no matter what i've accomplished you
truly believe that 1 000
and but i also approach the world in a
way that could make that real now i may
fail
but i'm in sincere pursuit of something
that is bigger than what i did in the
past
now whether i achieve it or not to be
honest again because of my value system
is irrelevant i don't
value accomplishment i value sincere
pursuit
now to get that you have to understand
what i mean by sincere like you've
really got to [ __ ] show up like i'm
trying to build the next disney okay
odds are i'm gonna fail but i go into it
sincerely and
every time i catch myself where it's
like this is even
remotely close to being just rhetoric
and not actually how i'm acting and
moving in the world
then i call [ __ ] and i immediately
change my approach
i am sincerely pursuing building the
next disney
every day and that like i value myself
for that so going back to like what are
these
you know big moments of change so one i
left i had a teaching job that was very
secure i left to go work with
entrepreneurs i thought that would be
really
um enlightening and so that everyone
thought it was crazy job because you
were
because i i had heard something very
potent
and has continued to be a guiding light
in my life which is if you want to
control the art
you have to control the resources and so
i thought okay
if i want to like imagine as a race car
driver what if you never needed a
sponsor
what if you had 10 billion dollars in
the bank and you were kicking off more
in weekly interest than racing would
cost you in a year
like all of a sudden it's like well i
don't have to do anything i
do this exactly the way that i want yeah
and so i had written a screenplay got
turned into a film it was total garbage
i was absolutely heartbroken and
that saying just came back with full
force if you want to control the art you
have to control the resources so i
thought okay
here i am sky trying to break into
hollywood here are these two successful
entrepreneurs
they're telling me that they can teach
me the principles of business that i
could get rich
let's do that so i go work with them and
then i after eight and a half years of
working with them i completely burn out
and chasing money
um even though it made me wealthy on
paper on paper
which is very different than bank
account but on paper i was worth about
two million dollars
and i gave their equity back i walked
away from it all i quit i said look i
can't keep doing this chasing money
was had left me emotionally bankrupt so
i was like
this isn't fun i need to feel alive and
so i quit that was another moment of
huge change ironically though it didn't
stick and they were like hey we want to
keep working with you
it's a whole another story and then we
end up building quest as a result of
that because that was the only way that
i would continue to
work with them is if we were doing
something we really believed in and that
ends up being quest for three very
different reasons and then
after about seven years a quest i'd
leave again and
now exited that and started impact
theory and
so impact theory itself which i hope
will be my forever company but
it will need to constantly be making
dramatic progress
um otherwise if i'm where i'm at now 10
years from now i'd be
deeply dissatisfied so you said you had
emotional
you were emotionally tapped from the job
that was essentially
making you wealthy on paper
talk about that like what what do you
mean you were emotionally
emotionally spent in that way you're
going to dig this because you're way
into energy
yeah all right so because i i i have i
have a thought on that i'd love to hear
like
why were you tell me about that emotion
because you were getting essentially
something that you wanted
yes and it didn't bring me what i
actually needed i mean it's like a pop
song in the making
um so yeah i really really since the
time i was a little kid i've been
telling people that i'm gonna be rich
i'm gonna be rich and i just believed it
um as they say in the matrix balls to
bones
and i knew i would make that come true
in my life i didn't know how
but i knew that i was going to do it and
so i
followed all the things um you know be
careful where
what does your dad say you're you look
where your eyes where you go you go
where your eyes go
yeah so that like be very careful
because
for me it was always identified as rich
i'm gonna get
rich it wasn't identified like i'm gonna
serve other people and generate wealth
doing it it was like i'm gonna get rich
sure and so
that's all i thought about saw an
opportunity to get rich in a software
company spent eight and a half years
trying to build the software company
it was security software so it wasn't
something i was passionate about
so you were bored i was bored i was just
trying to be a slick marketer
and know thyself right so i am big on
connection
so i want to connect with people i want
to feel like i matter i want to know
that what i'm doing adds value to the
world i like community
i'm the kid that at like age five i
pretended not to see easter eggs so my
sister
who was nine could find them because i
knew it meant more for her
women five and your sister was nine and
because i knew she like she really got
off on winning whereas for me
i really got off on seeing her excited
so like my thing is work
and this goes back to predisposition for
whatever reason
i'm wired to really neurochemically
enjoy
being a part of a team and seeing other
people succeed like that's rad for me
so fantastic that you can identify with
that i think that's a good lesson for
people to identify what motivates them
what feels good unfortunately though
instead of really dumb [ __ ]
well you know we all go through a
learning process and that's part of the
journey but to identify
you know to be able to identify that for
yourself
through observation and honesty instead
of
following the masses and you know
society's acceptance for success
yeah i really wish i'd come to it faster
but you're right
i'm grateful that i got there in the end
so
um by the end of that time i felt dead i
mean
it's just steering by what did that mean
describe that because there's i'm going
to guarantee there are people out there
that are exactly that they might be
doing okay but they're bored off their
ass they're not doing a job that's fun
they're totally uninspired
and let's face it the work that you do
affects your home
too so just like your home affects your
work so
you know they both go hand in hand so
what was the
consequence of being emotionally tapped
yeah i'm glad you said that so
my wife pulled me aside and i was
i thought getting rich would take 18
months
and so i kept telling my wife like just
let me run hard for 18 months 18 months
18 months
18 months and so at six and a half years
she pulled me aside oh my gosh
and she said you're now damaging the
marriage and you're
so focused and you work around the clock
and it's always head down and
sort of always beating yourself up
because you're not you know where you
want to be and it's taking too long
that it's it's not fun anymore for her
and it's certainly not good
excuse me for the marriage so i took
that very seriously because my highest
priority is my marriage
over getting wealthy even back then like
the one
wise thing i will say is that i've
always gotten more out of my marriage
than i've gotten out of
anything else so parents were your
parents good examples for that
no oh that's for the example of exactly
what not okay well that happens right
they you can your parents a smoker so
you're not or you are too
you know right like yes and it's okay i
mean that you want to talk about a
tangent that would
actually be quite interesting to go down
for me anyways
um i at 14 my parents seemed happily
married because i'm a kid and i don't
know what unhappily married looks like i
just know
my parents are together and so other
parents are divorced and my parents are
not and so
i must be happily married but starting
at about the age of
i don't know 12 to 14 somewhere around
in there i started having a recurring
nightmare of being in a loveless
marriage
and i could not understand i was like
i've never dated anybody
so why why is my nightmare being in a
loveless marriage
wow and so that haunted me for years and
then three weeks after i went to college
my dad left
oh wow so and actually like mad respect
to dad like
i wouldn't do the same courtesy to my
children if i were in in a loveless
marriage i would get the
[ __ ] out yeah yeah um but my dad stuck
it out
didn't leave when my sister left
literally waited wow
and do you know how there are so many
people that do that and
you know i've had this conversation
before with with friends like
you know you stay for the kids and it's
like you are
you are showing your children that not
being affectionate that not being
friendly
that walking past each other or not
uh not not not loving
not operating in a loving way is normal
and your children are bound to repeat it
so how did you
how the hell did you not repeat it then
you saw it you had the
we talked about this earlier you you go
bmx racing and every time you bmx do the
flip you crash so don't do that so
you obviously get messages through your
dreams um which is interesting no
never thought of myself like that so but
one thing there you go good that's for
sure
you know and sure and so your parents
separate
and how did you how did that um
number one how to affect you and then
number two how did you become the man
you are today
in a relationship well i think people
have to have rules in life so
it starts with that and it starts with
i'm
you're gonna think i'm being um modest
i'm not so
follow me for a second even though in
the beginning you're gonna think this is
stupid
um i'm just dumb enough that
i have to like grope my way through
things to figure them out
but i'm just smart enough to actually be
able to do it
so when i'm looking at my life and i'm
like whoa something
really doesn't feel right it's not
usually immediately
apparent why it doesn't feel right and
certainly when i was younger
and so i'm like ooh something isn't
feeling good um but i'm going to turn
inward and i'm going to try to figure
out what it is now when you turn inward
especially when i was young
i had it's it's called the psychological
immune system and the psychological
immune system its
job is to to cut it short is to keep you
from committing suicide
so you [ __ ] up you do something really
stupid and
by all intents and purposes your
self-esteem should fall to nothing but
it won't
the psychological immune system kicks in
and it tells you it wasn't your fault it
was stacked against you
it was their fault the world did this
the world did that aka coping mechanisms
correct so you have all these coping
mecha mechanisms that kick in
and because i was so
hell-bent to get rich i had the moment
of crisis already walked
you through where it forced my
psychological immune system to come to
grips with the truth
and in that moment i said okay well
what do you really want and it's okay
whatever the answer is it's okay if it's
petty if it's
ugly if it's something you never want to
admit to another person
it's okay like in my own mind it was
like hey this is a safe space to say
what you
actually want and so in that moment of
being able to say what i actually wanted
i realized what i
actually wanted was to succeed but the
way i was going about success what i was
defining as success was problematic
and the thing that i was building my
self-esteem around was problematic
and i had the the how did i become the
man i am today i had the realization
that everything in your what what i will
call your operating system
is malleable your beliefs are malleable
your
values are malleable your identity is
malleable so people think well i grew up
in a christian household therefore i
have to have christian values or i grew
up in a muslim household i have to have
muslim values it's just not true
like and that's that is but one random
[ __ ] fact just to get people
an understanding because they'll get it
like oh i grew up in this religion or i
didn't and they see how it permeates
their thinking
but there's a thousand other things your
thinking is permeated with by the
country you grew up in the state the way
your parents are your zip code like
it's the books you read it's terrifying
the way this stuff seeps in
usually it happens by accident people
don't take control of their value system
they don't take control of their belief
system they mistake
values and beliefs for truth and they
are not truth
it isn't it isn't objectively true that
anything is possible
but i live as if it were so that is a
belief i have i believe human potential
is nearly limitless
cool maybe it's not maybe it's so far
maybe it's so crushingly limited but i
don't care
it doesn't help me to act like that so
anyway cobbling all this stuff together
is how i become the person i am today
now how did i become the way i am in
relationships this answer is at least
funny
i read cosmo magazines so starting out
great
i was absolutely terrified that i'd be
bad at sex
so when i was a teenager i had no game
none whatsoever i did not know how to
flirt with women
i actually did a sereno de bergerac
because my talent was always verbal
so for everybody i'll i'll explain it so
uh all of us get early wins in something
so the more energy you put into it you
get an exaggerated response i'm gonna
guess that's you with
driving which is why you and your sister
did it at the same time you got
exaggerated response you keep doing it
she stops
so for whatever reason just verbally i
had to work my
ass off at it and i've never put more
time and attention into anything in my
life
more than verbal but i was always
getting a disproportionate return on my
energy
so in my teenage years me and my best
friend
fell for the same girl but i was so
terrified to approach her and he had all
the confidence in the world
but he was terrible verbally so i
actually and this
this comes from the place here no de
bergerac where this guy with a really
long nose
helps this other guy woo the woman that
he loves so i'm in the bushes telling my
friend what to say and he's
literally at her window wooing the girl
that i
and that's some you're just using that
as a figurative example because that's
what they did in the player that's
no that's what happened later i'm
literally oh my god my friend
thought you were just describing the way
i threw rocks at her window
no the whole nine and i thought oh my
god this is so pathetic i'm
actually living out sierra not a burst
right that is the example of giving your
sis letting your sister get the easter
egg that's part of the conflict but
this one really came from a place of
emotional weakness i was
i was too afraid to be rejected
and um so again how do i become this
person i'm willing to admit
that that was emotional weakness and my
journey has been one of toughening up
emotionally yeah the thing i didn't know
how to do in business the thing that i
finally had to learn in order to get
good
is be tough okay so were you a pushover
were you just sensitive were you easily
offended
tell me what it means to be tell me what
it means to be
uh to to need to work on the emotional
side
i was afraid of physical confrontation
which as a guy makes you afraid of
verbal confrontation because
does it go with a girl or physical well
fit
definitely are we talking about
face-to-face sort of conversations and
hiring and firing or well how does it
play out in a civil context it plays out
in a civil context yeah that you're
afraid of confrontation
is the easiest way of of any kind once
you're afraid of confrontation you're
afraid of the truth once you're afraid
of the truth you can't be effective
no wonder why i love truth because i'm
really good at confrontation
that's amazing and more powerful maybe
than you realize yeah so
because i was so [ __ ] afraid of it it
really governed
everything in my life and so my life was
about overcoming that
yeah yeah that was one of the biggest
things i've had to learn huh
so now back to leaving this miserable
job that you were at but you were being
financially successful at but not um
emotionally successful at
in fact you were you were you were
falling away to
to something to a place that was
affecting your core values
you start making quest bars
in your kitchen with some friends yes uh
so
how did you decide all of a sudden like
i'm gonna make a fitness bar
so it goes just like this uh these there
were two things when i was a kid i
promised myself that i would ultimately
have and that was that i would be
wealthy and i would have six-pack abs
and growing up a slightly chubby kid and
a morbid leopard yes
you've been successful thank you i
haven't seen your abs but you
look fit thank you um it that would that
was a a real
a real journey like that that one wasn't
easy um but now for a second isn't the
journey interesting while you were
successful and maybe i don't know about
the fitness part like
look at you now like it's far better the
bigger than what you could have ever
imagined probably right
like the in the journey is really
interesting the journey is really
interesting you and i are
lockstep on that i've always been able
to dream big as [ __ ]
so so you're rich was two million
dollars and i'm gonna bet you got more
than that
yeah that's i don't know that i had a
number but
once i was old enough to have a number
it was bigger than
even now my net worth on paper is more
than that number but
my bank account isn't but so the the
party
a whole big lesson on um assets being
your wealth and bank accounts being high
or not really true wealth
yeah people people really have to
understand the difference between yeah
when you're
if you're worth a lot on paper like my
my net worth on paper is
is pretty terrifying and then
my bank is ridiculous do not get me
wrong right i'm just saying there's
there is a vast discrepancy like if you
were to go online right now and search
what's tom bilyeu's net worth you'll get
a roughly accurate number
but if it isn't the number that i'm
getting paid interest on if that makes
sense
right so and and that just gets into
finance
people really need to understand that
[ __ ] and i didn't understand it for a
very long time
um anyway back to quest bar so yes i uh
i go in and i'm i'm unhappy and i quit
and they were completely caught off
guard
but these guys the reason that i ended
up with them is because they were yoked
bodybuilders and very successful
entrepreneurs so they were the two
things i wanted to be
fit and rich okay so i was like i'm
following you but you went in and you
were
you did the you did the verbal
confrontation you know you
you're good with words but the emotion
was there so you left was that a
had you worked with that sort of side of
you that was um
needing the work at that point in time
were you finally arriving at a good
place where you could say i'm done
and feel i'm still not where i want to
be so it would be a lie to say that i
felt like i was done but i'd come
so far by that point okay i was very
effective at business but now it's time
for the six-pack
yeah well so i um i'm already working on
this
no that's not quite true so i quit at
this six and a half year mark but we
don't actually end up
exiting the company until eight and a
half years roughly so six and a half
year mark i say hey i'm done i can't do
this anymore
and they say what would it take for us
to keep working together and i outline
vagaries i say uh it needs to be
something we're passionate about it
needs to be something that adds value to
people it needs to be community based it
needs to be our real personalities like
all the things that i was about because
i'd already quit i'd done the hard thing
so i was like hang on but you're going
to keep working with these people
but this was they were asking that when
i had already quit
oh so now they're trying to get me back
back in that job or back in
any job back to work together so they're
like when i quit
they were like okay god wow [ __ ] i
didn't see that coming by thank you
and i leave okay and i'm i'm going home
and the weight of the world has been
lifted off my shoulders because they
were like my brothers
so i was like i felt like i was leaving
them high and dry
but i was but i felt free for the first
time in a very long time and so
driving home i am pulling into my
driveway and my phone rings and i'm on
the phone with my wife i did it because
we were going to move to greece we're
moving to greece
oh my gosh
so we were gonna bone out and i'm
pulling into the driveway and i say babe
it's uh it's it's them calling let me
let me
take this out of respect so i click over
and they say
we could do this without you but we
don't want to
so come come out to dinner with us and
so i go out to dinner and they were like
look you
totally caught us by surprise you didn't
know what to say
we've had time to think about it and we
don't want to do this without you
so what would it take for us to work
together and so i was like
this meaning like we don't want you to
go away we love you we want to work with
you
what capacity are you willing to work
with us correct
okay and so then i broke it down and i
said
you know this is what it would have to
look like and it was um
the things that i just outlined and they
were like actually we've been unhappy
for a long time as well let's set a goal
metrics and if we don't hit the metrics
we'll sell the company and
um and we'll start something new and so
at the time we didn't know what we were
going to start
okay and so then you start looking at
the assets you've got me i'm obsessed
with community i'm obsessed with
filmmaking
and all that and you've got my partner
who is
who the punch line will end up being
that he's really good at operations
and that becomes very necessary in the
business we decided to start and then my
other partner who was
just obsessed with nutrition i mean the
guy was obsessed
and so we're out of technology i'd be
that friend oh it was
awesome so he would come in and talk
about nutrition all the time and so we
were all like
all the people that complained that
there's too much noise out in the world
of fitness and who do you listed we were
all just like we listened to him
yeah and so he was yolked ripped
whatever he was working yeah we're like
fox you tell us what to do and we'll do
it yeah
and so he would tell people most people
wouldn't do it but i actually would and
i followed through and it works
completely changed my physique added
muscle got lean like it was incredible
and
all that time now we're like well what's
our next business we're like well
the thing that we talk about when we're
in neutral we're not trying to get rid
of whatever
is always nutrition okay and so then i'm
like well what would be my hook into
that i love it personally but not enough
to show up and fight every day
but my mom and my sister are morbidly
obese now that i can get behind i can
show up and fight for my family
so then i just started investing right
taking my value system and saying okay
i'm going to end metabolic disease and
i'm going to help my mom and my sister
and there's a great mother teresa quote
she says nobody will act for the many
but people will act for the one so i'm
like i'm just gonna show up and fight
for those two i'm gonna think about them
it's easy to picture it's easy to
imagine i know i'm gonna lose them too
soon
because they just they're not making the
right food choice yeah it's gonna kill
so if we can make food that they choose
based on taste and it happens to be good
for them
then we've got something and my other
two partners were doing it for very
different reasons
as much as they cared about my mom and
my sister
they weren't showing up every day and
fighting for them nor would i expect
them to
so we each had our own reason to want to
be there but if you align selfish
desires you can do some pretty
extraordinary things and since i was in
charge of marketing
i could just tell my story like look
here was my own weight loss journey
and i come from this morbidly obese
family and i want to help them and i am
not stupid i know that there are
hundreds of millions maybe a billion or
more people that struggle with food
exactly the way that they do and so that
became the the guiding light of the
company
and metabolic disease well belief is a
powerful thing as we talked about
um but then i think the next most
powerful thing is is
have to do something there's a
difference like when you have to so
i'm going to bet that you probably fell
into that sort of
role of feeling like you had to do
something right and you were looking for
something anyway it fit the
you know it became a very motivating
like i want to help save their life like
this needs to be done
um okay so what were the
i mean what what uh
like you started in a kitchen then there
was
you bought the equipment for um
producing the product because you didn't
want to have to do it
and then somebody else said they
couldn't do it and sure enough you tried
it and
it the equipment didn't work and then
someone rebuilt it who the hell was the
mechanic
yeah so that's a fun story so like you
said we started making them by hand to
prove the market so we were already
selling them just making them in a
kitchen we were renting by the hour
just never planning long term to do it
ourselves but we needed to see if there
was a market worth investing so we see
there is we go to contract manufacturers
we say here's our recipe and they all
say this cannot be made
and we didn't believe them anything is
possible hey we'll do this ourselves
it's probably better anyway i remember
my partner coming in and saying
we're going to be our own manufacturers
and me and my other partner were like
you're out of your [ __ ] mind
why would we ever do that and that ended
up being really really an important
inflection point for us because now we
could figure out
how to make the bar and what we realized
was people had probably had a recipe
like ours for a long time one that
doesn't use sugar
and that tastes like it does but every
time they went to a contract
manufacturer and they said this can't be
made then they just stopped
or they changed their recipe sure what
we did instead was
design our own equipment so we bought
equipment that
was used for traditional protein bars
and what we realized was
high fructose corn syrup has very
specific properties in terms of texture
and the way that it runs through the
machine
we've been using high fructose corn
syrup for like 70 years the equipment
has all grown up
in lockstep with the use of high
fructose corn syrup so it's literally
designed to take certain
textures we didn't think about how sort
of in lockstep they would be and as soon
as you take that ingredient out and put
in another one even if it's another
liquid once it's a liquid fiber which is
what we were using it just doesn't react
the same as the machine would lock up
oh boy so we're like all right we have
to fix the stuff one of my partners was
quite literally an iowa farm boy and i
remember one day he's looking at the
equipment
and we're all like [ __ ] this isn't
working like it's disaster everything's
all over the place pick it it might
run yeah and um mike looked at it and he
goes
i think i know how to fix this and we're
all like what
and so he was like but if i do it
there's no going back we won't be able
to resell the equipment
and so having a very high tolerance for
risk we're like yeah
we're dead in the water now you might as
well at least try it and so with a
sawzall
and a blowtorch oh my god cut it apart
oh my god
it back together and it worked and we
were like
did you guys watch the money just going
into the shredder as he got the sawzall
out and he just started
hacking away because that's that's not
even very accurate so it's all
they use sawzalls at the racetrack when
you get into an accident you have to cut
body work off
sawzall baby yeah and i took pictures of
it because i'm like no one's ever gonna
believe this
like it was just that do or die [ __ ]
like there's there is a
very fun period in an entrepreneur's
life where it's just all do or die and
if
you if you have a sense of fun about it
like i've always believed in myself
and my wife and that that like you very
graciously
talked about earlier i will give the
same caveat that doesn't mean that i
don't doubt myself
routinely it just means that i also
believe in myself routine yeah
so i i was like if this doesn't work out
and it tanks cause we all put our houses
up
um wow it's like okay we lose the house
and stuff as long as i don't have brain
damage and nothing happens to my wife
i can always rebuild those two things
though i legitimately have fear of
so brain damage scares me just like to
to my knees because then there's there's
just nothing
no without your health you have nothing
correct you're locked to a bed
most things you can fight back from but
brain injury yeah
so this confidence is something i want
to talk about because i think that it's
um
it's not the most common thing but you
have i want to make sure
i wrote it down because it was important
if you can out execute
out execute me then you deserve the
success not me and i think that
that is a really freaking confident
statement
because and you also had mentioned
something about
also being willing to share information
and secrets and like it's not
it's basically you're saying mono amano
where the hell did you get that
confidence to be willing to
give each other give other people you
know
all the tools and say let's go
you ready for the real secret yeah
that's not actually what i'm doing
so what i'm really doing is going some
people are going to think this is
manuimano and they're going to take it
and try to outperform me
and on a long enough time my one piece
of arrogance is on a long enough
timeline no one is willing to do what
i'm willing to do they will fall off
and life has just taught me that is the
[ __ ] gospel truth we talked about
that the try harder one more time
they keep going one more time and they
keep going one more time and they just
keep dropping off until you're the last
man standing or woman whatever it is a
thousand percent
and that's why when you said that i was
like that's intoxicating me
that is that is the very thing that my
success is predicated on
is i'm i'm i'm relentless
like let the full weight of that word
wash over you i am relentless
i will not stop i'm like the [ __ ]
terminator so
get that from the movie no where'd you
get the confidence from
that um well here is someone in your
family that way no
did you hear were you using
neuroplasticity to
train your brain this is what
breakthrough moment for everybody
you need to you need to have a rule in
your life that says exactly the
following
i only do and believe
that which moves me towards my goals
so if thinking that you're too stupid to
do it moves you towards your goals then
think you're stupid
but something tells me that's probably
not what's going to take you towards
your goal right thing that's going to
take you towards your goal is to believe
that you can figure it out
so i adopted the belief system of the
learner
now then in terms of like values and
stuff my identity and my value system is
such that i need to be able to endure
more suffering than the next person so
you put them together i believe i can
learn anything
my very identity and ego is tied up in
the willingness to
learn not to be smart to learn to follow
my face and get back up
and i'm not going to let somebody out
suffer me
cool you put those two together you have
a dangerous cocktail by the way you get
a guy that goes six and a half years
down a path that's making him profoundly
unhappy so that is a very real
if you don't have all the other
mechanisms because my belief system has
25 points
you can download my belief system i
literally make it available
um and so to get them to get back nice
to get back to the original point
um i'm some people will take it as
monowi mono i know i will beat them
on a long enough timeline and then the
other people
are all going to want to help and
they're going to in some way shape or
form
help me sharpen my thinking assist me
right at a moment when i need it
i'm just a huge believer in tell people
what you're up to because you
never know who might want to help or who
might be able to help like
you could be standing next to somebody
who in my world let's say
is a film producer and they're
desperately looking for
let's say they have a philosophy i don't
bet on stories i bet on people
okay well cool if i'm standing next to
that guy and he knows what i'm trying to
accomplish
chances are he's gonna at least let me
sit down with him
now we all have a superpower that we
have cultivated
mine is if you get me in the room i will
make people believe
but you have to get me in the room and i
have to believe in it but if i believe
in it
oh my friend i can draw someone said
belief
belief is super powerful for sure but if
i don't tell people what i'm up to
they're never going to yeah so it isn't
about me saying hey here's everything
that i'm doing so that we can
go against each other here's everything
that i'm doing and i hope yeah
well you know that kind of leads me to
this you'd mention it a little bit at
the beginning but about
um like victim mentality of like you
know people
people just like if it's
if they can just believe in something
and have
authentic goals that mean something to
them whether you know changing their
mission
like why wouldn't everyone do that and i
just think that you're a great example
of grabbing a hold of what it is that
you're good at and
making that into something great you
know because not everyone has to be an
owner or the leader you know some people
need help and
you couldn't do it without them so what
do we do to get people to
take ownership for their life
get them into impact theory university
and and i say that not as a plug i said
that that is
because i designed
this is a very learnable thing and i
know because i did it i didn't start out
there i started out as an absolute
[ __ ] basket case
and i slowly but surely cobbled all this
stuff together out of desperation out of
a desire not to slide into depression
after meeting extraordinary people
reading extraordinary books i mean
basically
i've just cobbled together all this
stuff it's probably 80 percent from
encountering other people and ideas and
20 just trying to synthesize all that
and then the way that it bounces around
uniquely in my particular mind
but it is learnable once you learn it it
will change your life so profoundly as
you will be unrecognizable okay well
give me a couple of points of
if i was going to university tell me a
couple things that i'd learned let's get
people excited about it so they do it
too because
i believe in the collective if we can
all just be going toward
going in the right direction a higher
frequency direction or whatever that is
i want everyone to do that in the world
will be a better place
and um let's stop playing the blame game
so
and let's all get along so so if i'm
going to university hook me
so one of the things you're going to
learn is something you just talked about
which is extreme ownership why most
people can't
take extreme ownership what it actually
means how to implement it in your life
you're going to learn about
neuroplasticity
why brain plasticity matters how to take
advantage of it
how to create empowering habits um the
exact beliefs that you should have in
order
the books you should read in order
you're going to get the
the values the what i call the ultimate
value stack
depending on what you want the value
stack is going to change but my thing is
i want this to be tactical so i'm not
going to say things like you need values
i'm going to say you need values and for
this thing that we're talking about
today
this is the ultimate value stack you
need to have this as a value whether
it's
a willingness to suffer more than the
next person that i do hard things every
day like
we're gonna break those down and then
i'm gonna give you what those things are
what are hard things that you should be
doing every day depending on where
you're trying to go like what are things
that would really work for you
um what i want impact theory university
to be
is an instruction manual for exactly how
to live
yeah so that and to accomplish so we
have two tracks there's the personal
which is all mindset but taking mindset
out of the ether and making it ultra
tactical do this love it think like this
calls to action
actually freaking accomplish something
definitively
and then business where it'll be just
straight up this is how you [ __ ]
build a business so yeah
sleeves up and let's go because we're
gonna get real specific yeah
well you like to read right obsessively
yes so you said read these books in
order so let's finish off give us a book
to read
number one give me a book there's
nothing else don't read anything other
than mindset by carol dweck
that is the most important set by carol
dweck writing that's that by carol dweck
it's the most
important book in the english language
i'm writing my own book right now and i
can just tell you you still need to read
carol dweck's book first that's awesome
like it is so powerful
um it is the framework upon which
everything else rests because it's the
most sort of base level fundamental
shift you're going to make in your mind
and until you make that shift you're not
ready for everything that comes after it
and that's
that book is all about the difference
between a fixed mindset where you
believe your talent
and intelligence are fixed traits
they're genetically determined that's
it's not 50
changeable it's 100 unchangeable a
growth mindset
is where sure maybe some of that is
fixed but you can actually
change your talent and intelligence
which is the one people normally get
hung up on
yeah so if you believe that they are
malleable traits you now have what i
call
the only belief that matters yeah now
why is it the only belief that matters
because
if you believe your talent or your
excuse me your energies
will be rewarded with an increase in
your talents then you'll actually put
the energy and the time into making the
change
if however you believe no matter how
much time and energy i put into this i'm
never going to improve because you can't
teach an old dog new tricks
then you won't put the energy in and
you'll never see that right on the other
side of a little bit of effort is this
insane gold mine
so people have the other side is through
correct the only way to the other side
is through stretch yourself i'm with you
all right cool thanks tom we got to wrap
up i wish i could do this longer but
thanks for having me on the guest so
smart
i think we're going to do part two
thanks everybody for listening to the
pretty intense podcast today i hope you
enjoyed it
if you like what you heard today and you
want to hear more please click on the
subscribe
button